für sein Beitrag und gebe nun das Wort
an seine
exzellenz-herren will Vladimir selensky
den Präsidenten der Ukraine
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Vorsitzender
Generalsekretär sehr geehrte Anwesenden
und Teilnehmer
hoffentlich werde heute dafür gehört
auch von allen UNO Mitglieder Staaten
heute war ich in der Stadt budja
in dieser Stadt haben die russischen
Militär
die ukrainischen Bürger
gezielt gesucht und vernichtet sie haben
eine Frauen Erwachsene
[Musik]
ältere Menschen und Kinder getötet na
hier haben sie mehrmals versucht die
Leichen zu verbrennen
und
wir werden diese
Opfer
in unserer Erinnerung behalten
in ihren Häusern getötet sie wurden mit
den Panzern einfach in den Straßen
getötet
mit Genuss gefoltert sie wurden getötet
vor Augen der Verwandten
vergewaltigt vergewaltigt
System sehr interessieren
und
[Musik]
da gibt es keinen Unterschied
zu den Handlungen der Terroristen von
islandstaat
und dieser Terrorismus
zerstört die Beziehungen zwischen den
Ländern und Staaten auf dieser Erde und
unser Feind bekämpft
die Nationalitäten in unserem Land
und möchte möglichst mehr Städte in
unserem Land zu zerstören
und wir sehen alle der Feind zerstörte
Städte und hinterlässt nur die
Massengräber
durch sein propagandas System versucht
unser Feind dieser Verhältnisse über die
ganze Welt zu verbreiten die
Nahrungskrise herbeizuführen die
Stabilität auf dem Nahrungsmittelmarkt
zu unterholen
und da frage ich mich wo ist die
Sicherheit die der Sicherheitsrat
eigentlich gewährleisten sollte nee
dieser
Sicherheit haben wir nicht und wo ist
der Frieden
den die UNO
gewährleisten sollte
Effekt
wir leider müssen verstellen dass die
UNO nicht effektiv arbeiten kann
jetzt haben wir vor Augen das
schreckliche Beispiel von Butcher aber
in anderen Städten und Gebieten des
Landes haben die Okkupant noch
schlimmere Taten angerichtet
die
Verbrecher sind
schrecklich und die Verantwortung soll
unabwendbar sein ich möchte auch
den Statut der UNO erinnern was ist
unser Ziel was ist das Ziel der UNO die
Erhaltung des friedes Friedens und wenn
es wirklich so ist
warum haben wir
die auf dem Staatsterritorium die
Ukraine den Krieg und warum eigentlich
bei uns die schrecklichsten
Kriegsverbrecher getan werden
dass russische Militär legt bewusst die
ukrainische Städte in Asche
für die Luftangriffe auf unsere
Siedlungen
greift die flüchtlingskolonne an und
beschied die Menschen die Schutz suchen
unsere Feinde
schaffen bewusst solche
[Musik]
Situationen auf den Besitzenden
Territorien dass es möglichst mehr
Menschen ums Leben kommen Botschaft das
ist halt ein Beispiel ein ein krasses
Beispiel dafür was seit dem Kriegsanfang
auf unseren Gebieten passiert in
ukrainischen Städten über den georg in
Dutzenden von ukrainischen Gemeinden wie
Butcher da passieren die ähnlichen
Verbrechen ich weiß sehr gut und sie
wissen auch nicht schlecht als ich was
die russischen Vertreter
zu diesem Thema sagen werden das haben
sie mehrmals gesagt schon getan
zum Beispiel was haben Sie in Syrien
gesagt sie werden alles dementieren sie
werden alles alle Beschuldigungen
ablehnen
und sich darauf
berufen dass es momentan leider nicht so
mit Sicherheit
feststellen werden könnte aber
wir schreiben heute das Jahr 2022 und
es gibt unwiderrufliche Beweise zum
Beispiel die Satelliten auf
Fotoaufnahmen und wir sind durchaus
an der maximal offenen Ermittlung des
Falles interessiert
mit
Heranziehung des internationalen
kriminalgerichtshofes
und unter Anwendung der allen
Kapazitäten der UNO wir müssen die
Kriegsverbrecher zur Verantwortung
ziehen und die Menschen
bestrafen die sich unstrafbar fühlen wir
müssen beweisen dass die Strafe
unabwendbar unabwendbar ist und das
damit setzen wir ein
Zeichen für die künftige Zeiten
System Vertriebenen naschebar hast du
die nasche also unser Feind braucht
unser Reichtum unser Land und unsere
Menschen die Russen haben schon
tausende von unseren Menschen entführt
zum Beispiel tausende Kinder und die
Russen machen es weiter heilen weiterhin
die Russen wollen uns
verwandeln zu den
schweigenden Sklaven sie plündern unsere
Städte sie stehlen alles was sie nur
können von Nahrungsmittel bis
Goldschmuck
und zugleich will Russland sein
Vetorecht in der UNO zu missbrauchen um
seine Schuld zu vertuschen
und das kann natürlich nicht für Frieden
und Sicherheit in der Welt arbeiten
und
das heißt dass die Länder nur auf ihre
Waffen errechnen können
soll ist es wirklich so dass in der Welt
nur das Recht des starken gilt
wenn es wirklich so ist dann
müssen wir einfach die UNO schließen
auf jeden Fall wir müssen jetzt
Eingreifen jetzt müssen wir der UNO die
Stärke die Kraft zurückgeben wir müssen
da durchsetzen dass das Vetorecht ein
Vetorecht in der Sicherheitsrat nicht
zum todesrecht
des also Christus wird
wir müssen die schreckliche Kette von
Massen Kriegsverbrechern
massenmorder von
Syrien bis auf die Ukraine unterbrechen
und wenn ein Aggressor eine
entschlossene Abfuhr erfahren wird dann
können wir erst dann über die bessere
Welt sprechen und vielleicht unter
solchen Bedingungen würde
Krieg in meinem Land der Krieg gegen
mein Volk gegen die Menschen in meiner
Heimat endlich
eingestellte werden
die Welt hat die Okkupierung der Krim
der Angriff auf Georgien
ignoriert
und die russische Rolle in vielen
anderen Konflikten übersehen
aber heute gilt es die russischen
Kriegsverbrecher sofort zur
Verantwortung zu ziehen
alle
russische Militär die die
verbrecherischen
Befehle erteilt haben und die dieser
Befehle ausgeführt haben müssen und
bedingt zur Verantwortung gezogen werden
und vor dem internationalen Gericht
verantworten ich möchte
erinnern
dass auch die Verantwortung sogar Adolf
Eichmann
eingeholt hat und
davon müssen wir uns alle
Beispiele nehmen
wir schlagen vor eine globale Konferenz
in der nächsten Zeit
einzuberufen um die Sicherheit die
Modernisierung des
Sicherheitssystems
auf dem Planet zu diskutieren was können
wir machen um die
Grenzen zu garantieren und die Rechte
der Staaten in Schutz nehmen
da können wir leider momentan
konstatieren die Ziele der UNO sind bis
jetzt nicht erreicht worden und jetzt
sind wir an der Reihe alle Anstrengungen
zu unternehmen um
die Sicherheit in der Welt und den
Frieden in der Welt zu garantieren
wir müssen
Entschlossenheit auf den Tag legen
gegen Aggressoren vorzugehen alle
Staaten müssen gleich behandelt werden
egal wie groß die Staaten sind
und die führende Kraft in der Welt soll
die Kraft des Friedens und der
Sicherheits werden und die
Ukraine ist bereit ihren Beitrag auf
diesem Gebiet zu leisten und wir können
die Plattform für so ein Gremium Gremium
und für so eine Konferenz anzubieten
dann
damit wir alle zusammen die
Präventivmaßnahmen zur Sicherung des
Friedens zu entwickeln
wir Ukraine
haben aus Afghanistan zum Beispiel über
1.000 Menschen evakuiert
also Afghaner die Menschen brauchten die
internationale Hilfe und
wir haben diesen Menschen geholfen egal
welcher Religion oder Nationalität sie
waren
für uns war es damals egal sind es
Ukrainer oder Ausländer
und
so sollten eigentlich alle in der Welt
vorgehen
und wenn es so wäre so würde die Welt
viel viel sicherer als bisher
wir müssen anderen helfen nicht nur in
den glücklichen Zeiten sondern in der
schlimmen Zeiten
und zwar für die Sicherheit in der
ganzen Welt
wie und wenn wir
wissen nicht wie das zu erreichen sind
da können wir
eines
tun entweder Russland von beschlussnahme
auf dem Gebiet der internationalen
Sicherheit zu beseitigen um den Frieden
zu garantieren oder
wir müssen
darüber nachdenken wir sollen wir
die UNO unformat umformatieren um die
Organisation effektiver zu gestalten und
die Alternative dafür wäre die
Selbstauflösung der Organisation also
wir brauchen Frieden europa braucht den
Frieden und die ganze Welt braucht den
Frieden und zum guten letzt ich möchte
Sie
bitten schauen Sie sich
kleines ein kurzes Video
das ist ein Video
darüber wie jemand
seine
Rechte missbrauchen kann
sie müssen sich dieses Video anschauen
weil nicht alle haben
die Möglichkeiten zu uns in die Ukraine
zu kommen ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]